und ich bin amerikaner und ich weiß die
sicherheit frieden freiheit wohlstand
deutschlands ist amerika wichtig ich
weiß auch für deutschland die
amerikanischen jetzt hinter ein
schicksal als partnerschaft ich liebe
dieses land leben schon lange hier bin
aber der meinung deutschland tut zu
wenig um sich selbst zu schützen
um andere regierungen in der
nachbarschaft zu beeinflussen um die
globalisierung in seinem sinne zu
gestalten weil deutschland ist so groß
und so reich und geostrategisch so
wichtig es kann nicht auf einfluss
verzichten
es kann auch nicht auf der konkurrenz
mit china und russland
verzichten er ist hatte eine rolle als
im kalten krieg jetzt bei der ukraine
ich habe schon gesagt dass deutschland
sollte lieber auf dem gaspedal ein
bisschen drücken statt immer nur auf der
bremse deutschland ist groß genug dass
auch führen sind von den ersten schritt
nehmen war ein bisschen ja jetzt mit
waffen
die die bundeswehr hat probleme das muss
man auch zugeben und wir haben uns sehr
verwundbar gemacht war deutschland ist
umschlagplatz und alles und gehandelt
und man ist ja verwundbar aber die
ukraine
können mit deutschen waffen
leben anderer ukraine retten und jetzt
sind die russen in so 20 prozent von der
ukraine wo bis zu zehn millionen leute
gelebt haben und wir wissen was sind
boka und den mario pohl passiert ist und
je schneller die ukraine die russen aus
dieser gegenden treiben kann desto
besser ist es irgendwann glaube ich mit
oder ohne deutsche waffen aber zu den
wird beeindruckt sein wenn die deutschen
waffen liefern denn das sind ja gerade
die pazifisten und wenn die dann in den
schlaf auch reingehe dann muss er neu
kalkulierten die angst bekam das kann
man frau war ja angst vor allem
deutschen revanchismus nein aber angst
dass sein plan den westen zu zersetzen
und deutschland immer so dazwischen zu
halten al arab al oh ja da
das bekommen dass es nicht auf frau
wagenknecht werden wir schaffen das
putin zu angst erstarrt naja also erst
mal deutschland liefert ja machen also
ist ja nicht so dass wir nichts liefern
also wenn das nicht alles lüge ist was
was die abwägung brüstet sich ja sogar
damit dass sie schwere waffen liefert
die frage ist was was hilft das den
menschen in der ukraine
ich meine dieser krieg läuft jetzt seit
über einem halben jahr und wir sehen die
russen kommen viel langsamer voran als
sie das dachten keine frage aber sie
kommen voran und sie werden
wahrscheinlich aus diesen gebieten
zumindest wenn es nicht auf dem
verhandlungsweg geht militärisch nicht
wieder raus zu kriegen sein dh der
einzige weg dieses sterben zu beenden
ist dass man eine diplomatische
initiative startet und dann wird immer
gesagt ich will ja gar nicht verhandeln
ja machen wir doch mal die probe aufs
exempel es wurde auch gesagt es lohnt
nicht überreizen lieferungen zu
verhandeln nur und haben die europäer
auch nichts gemacht man hat es erdogan
dem türkischen präsidenten überlassen
dass der dann die initiative ergriffen
hatten hat gesagt ja jetzt ich hol dir
jetzt an einen tisch und die sollen
jetzt mal bitte irgendwie sich
verständigen dass hier wieder weizen
schiffe durch schwarze meer fahren
können und es war erfolgreich
nur dann höre ich meine kann man
erhalten davon was man will gerhard
schröder hat offensichtlich einen draht
zu putin er war dort nichts erreicht
nicht märz einen menschen der communio
erreichen der kann doch nicht der kann
doch keine autorität zu verhandeln er
ist zurückgekommen hatte offenbar von
putin den auftrag hier die botschaft zu
verbreiten putin möchte verhandeln das
hat er gesagt also schröder kam zurück
und hat gesagt putin möchte verhandeln
er möchte den krieg auf verhandlungsweg
beenden ja das ist doch eine botschaft
da muss man doch anfangen auszuloten
okay natürlich kann man jetzt nicht
sagen also die verhandlungen bedeutet
russland besetzt die ukraine und wir
beenden dadurch den weg aber man muss
doch dann gucken wie kann man mit dem
reden wie kann man eine vereinbarung
finden statt immer nur zu sagen wer will
doch gar nicht also wenn man jetzt
schröder ist ein sprachrohr betrachtet
hat er uns vermittelt er möchte von
haben wir eine frau körpern als ich
würde ja schon sagen junge sliden fehlt
der spd in der 100 die spd denn genug
für fahren
jahres würde ich schon sagen dass die
spd genug tut und ich möchte noch mal
erinnern dass bevor der krieg ja losging
wie viele spitzenpolitiker olaf scholz
waren denn in russland an diesem langen
tisch wer diese bilder gesehen irgendwie
acht meter gefühlt entfernung zwischen
dem spitzenpolitiker und putin und haben
gesprochen es ist ja nicht so dass alle
zugeschaut haben und gesagt haben uns
ist das egal was da vor ort passiert es
wenn er genug leute da um mit putin zu
sprechen und ich glaube tatsächlich
nicht daran dass putin egal wer jetzt
hin fährt oder anruft und mit dem
verhandeln möchte dass er sagt ja dann
machen wir das jetzt so wir hören jetzt
mit dem krieg auf ich ziehe meine panzer
zurück ich glaube dann haben sie ein
bisschen zu einfach weil einfach im
vorfeld viel geredet worden ist und das
vergessene vielleicht ein bisschen aber
das ist ja im vorfeld schon einiges
passiert wobei der entscheidende
politiker gerade nicht da war und auch
nicht mit pudding geredet hatten das war
joe biden also es ging ja die wirklich
strittige frage seit jahren ist ja die
frage einer möglichen nato
mitgliedschaft das hat russland immer
als ein absolut rote linie betrachtet
und die usa haben trotzdem zunehmend die
ukrainische streitkräfte in die nato
integriert so und natürlich ist europa
deutschland hat damals das veto
eingelegt deswegen gab es keine formale
mitgliedschaft aber es gab auch nie eine
zusage dass zum beispiel keine
raketenbasen in die ukraine verlegt
werden wie es sie in polen und rumänien
und beiden hat es abgelehnt mit putin
darüber zu reden also das muss man auch
sehen das rechtfertigt den krieg nicht
also nicht dass ich jetzt hier wieder in
der weise interpretiert werde natürlich
ist der krieg trotzdem ein verbrechen
aber ich glaube dass man ihn vielleicht
hätte verhindern können durch solche
gespräche beiden hat sie nicht gefeuert
aber jetzt haben wir die situation so
wie sie jetzt ist es bringt ja nix
völlig
gegensätzlich aber auch sagen dann würde
es ja nur was bringen also bin ich ihre
argumentation folge dass es nur hilfen
würde wenn bei wenn joe biden mit ihm
sprechen hier sollten auch beide so
druck setzen ja also deswegen deswegen
mancher im vorfeld sind ja gespräche
glaube das hat dazu nichts geführt sw
also herr dennison warum das ist ja
schon eine sehr wichtige frage warum ist
joe biden nicht geflogen er wollte sich
nicht so der vermehren lassen da an
diesen lagen tisch zu sitzen wo puten
dann hoch hält ok jetzt beiden hat mit
ihnen gesprochen und das fehlen der
gruppe ich versuche ja einem anderen
land zu treffen wie zb also in warschau
getroffen aber das hätte es nicht mehr
also leute denken mit genug gespräche
können wir die probleme lösen es tut mir
leid ja aber man kann bis ende der tage
darüber sprechen putin wollte angreifen
tobt und die gespräche haben ihn nicht
davon abgehalten
und es ist auch so dass fehlende
verhandlungen und
verhandlungsbereitschaft ihn nicht daran
hindern den frieden zu suchen man ist
bereit mit ihnen zu reden aber waren
will nicht frieden um jeden preis und
für die ukraine geht es nicht um frieden
sondern um den sie das heißt dass die
besetzten gebieten werden befreit und
die verhandlung die kommen können denke
ich werden nur da sein wenn putin bereit
ist
den land zu räumen und ich kompromisse
das ist realistisch weil ich meinen sie
haben gesagt dass die russen weiter
fortschritte machen aber die die die
weite spektrum der meinung sagt dass
erstens bei den lebensmittellieferung es
war die ukrainische marine und die
raketen die die russische marine fenton
gehalten haben und dass sie aus legalen
besetzt haben dass putin meinte ich kann
das militärisch nicht mehr halten ich
lasse das kommt mir einmal zurück in
deutschland bin ich auch gesagt habe wir
müssen da jetzt stärke zeigen es sind ja
viele probleme da die möglich sind wie
zum beispiel auch mögliche blackouts da
würde ich gerne einmal ralf schuler
frage nach der stimmung in diesem land
der stimmung in der politik was man da
eigentlich erwartet für den winter man
erwartet ganz klar die einen sagen so
offen die anderen drücken sie noch
wissen darum mann erwartet eine
rezession also ein wirkliches absinken
der wirtschaftskraft die definition ist
wenn zwei quartale hintereinander ein
negatives wirtschaftswachstum
also wenn - weil beim wirtschaften
zu verzeichnen ist dass das dann schon
eine rezension ist das dürfte tiefer
werden also die berater auch im
finanzministerium gehen davon aus dass
das schon massiv werden wird der ifo
geschäftsklimaindex ist dafür ein ganz
guter
ein ganz gutes anzeichen also man geht
auch davon aus dass beispielsweise es
gibt sowieso bestimmte so ein bisschen
wie wirtschafts mystik wenn
beispielsweise die grundstoff produktion
für
produzierendes gewerbe also die die
basis materialien die man braucht und
die beimischung premiere wenn die
weniger bestellt werden da gehen die
firmen offensichtlich davon aus das ist
alles sehr heikel wird und dass man
nicht weiß ob man das geschäft aufrecht
erhalten kann also die stimmung ist mies
und auch die politik hat hohe angst
davor dass diese miese stimmung der
wirtschaft sich in rezessionen
niederschlägt in hohe inflation in hohe
energiepreise die dann wiederum
umschlagen in eine wut stimmung im
herbst die entlastungs paket ist
aufhören kann die entlastungs pakete
sind betreffen ja jetzt erst mal nur
mehr oder weniger treff genau
energie-preise es geht jetzt nicht darum
die die kurzarbeiter regelung ist schon
verlängert sodass also wenn es weitere
insolvenzen geben kann man kann da
vielleicht einige auffangen es ist aber
eigentlich auch allen klar dass wir
nicht die dritte große krise in folge
jetzt mit milliardenpaketen zu schützen
können so dass es möglichst schmerzfrei
an der bevölkerung vorübergeht und das
ist die ganz große angst die die gesamte
bundesregierung beseelt und wo sie auch
noch keine wirkliche antwort darauf
gefunden haben dass ist in der tat alles
sehr sehr angespannt und die das erste
paket was jetzt gerade beschlossen
worden ist ist ja erst mal nur formal
beschlossen und noch gar nicht in kraft
also das hat noch kein rentner seinen
300 euro bekommen
die studenten auch noch nicht und es
ist auch nicht ganz klar warum bei
riesen rentenerhöhungen die sind derzeit
gegeben hat man jetzt so tut als seien
die rentner vergessen worden die sind
nicht vergessen worden die haben bewusst
ausgeklammert da war es auch wieder
ungerecht ist weil es eben sehr niedrige
renten gibt und dann gibt es ganz gut
gestaltete pensionen die es nicht
wirklich nötig hätten das kann man aber
so nicht streuen das ist eine sehr
komplizierte geschichte das wirklich zu
puffern
man nennt das das gießkannenprinzip
gießkannenprinzip und intern ist
natürlich auch klar dass wenn es
wirklich zu einer harten rezession
kommen sollte dass dann die
schuldenbremse im nächsten jahr nicht
eingehalten wird aber das ist immer so
ein spiel in der politik man muss immer
erst die schmerzgrenze
spüren und dann kann man ja sagen ja
unter diesen bedingungen ich habe zwar
immer gesagt keine schuldenbremse aber
dann müssen das jetzt machen was soll
ich tun einzig echte ruhen uns denn
soziale unruhen ja ich glaube dass die
menschen protestieren müssen ich meine
was ich vorhin gesagt habe dass in
frankreich der sprit viel billiger ist
dass der strom viel billiger ist auch
gedeckelt ist das hat ja was damit zu
tun dass der makro angst hat vor gästen
protesten also vor allem wieder
aufflammen dieser gelb westen bewegung
und das hat dann immerhin zur folge dass
die regierung ein bisschen mehr sozial
macht
das brauchen wir in deutschland auch
wobei ich mir keine illusionen mache ich
meine der großhandelspreis für gas hat
sich verzehnfacht also selbst also wenn
man die sanktionen aufrecht erhält
könnte also die wohlwollende regierung
diese riesige differenz ja nicht
abfedern also das sind ja das ist ja
zwangsläufig immer nur tropfen auf den
heißen stein weil der staat hat ja auch
keine gelder sofort programm wenn sie
jetzt den
plan hätten also ich finde tatsächlich
wir müssen verhandeln über eine
wiederaufnahme der gaslieferung wir
haben keine andere chance es geht uns
die industrie kaputt und was weg ist ist
weg also das ja auch so wenn der habe
gesagt ja halogen paar kaputt aber die
kommen ja vielleicht wieder man hatte
auch letztens das handelsblatt noch mal
ganz klar analysiert zum beispiel
unternehmen die jetzt verlagert werden
die kommen nicht zurück der bedingung so
sagen sie sagen wiederaufnahme der
verhandlung welche konzession würden sie
putin waren so dass er wieder gas
fließen lässt ja erstmal müsste man
hören also ich glaube dass arbeitet ist
mein glauben das muss man halt
verhandeln wenn wir zwei öffnungen
würden das wahrscheinlich fließen würde
aber weiß ich nicht muss man die nächste
turbine wieder kaputt also ich meine das
interesse soll denn putin daran haben
dass er jetzt wieder liefert die märkte
nehmen das als signal einer entspannung
der preis geht wieder runter jetzt kann
putin sehr viel weniger liefern und
nicht mehr geld ein ideal warum sollte
er das öffnen nur damit weitergeht neben
ort zum 2 natürlich für russland sondern
art prestige projekt ist ich weiß es
nicht aber wir müssen noch versuchen
kann auch sein dass er sagt ja gut das
machen wir aber nur wenn ihr die
enteignung unser zentralbankreserven
rückgängig macht oder wenn wir unsere
banken weder beim schiff dabei sind aber
wir müssen doch einfach sehen das
gesamte sanktionspaket und wie gesagt
dass auch die unehrlichkeit oder 1 bei
sind ja wie gesagt sieben große
sanktionspaket die eu gemacht hat so
haben wir noch nie auf einen krieg
reagiert und die welt ist voll von
völkerrechtswidrigen schlimmen kriegen
also ganz angeführt von den usa den
nächsten jahren sollen länder amerikaner
wie gesagt also wir müssen ja gar nicht
wir können unseren nato verbündeten
türkei nehmen die besetzen auch aktuell
völkerrechtswidrig in nordsyrien und
daher weise im irak gebiete die haben
ich würde sagen kein tugend ok angst ist
kein trugen in deutschland hartig
berliner blockade überstanden
deutschland westdeutschland hat opec öl
embargo überstanden deutschland wird das
auch überstehen wenn die deutschen
verstehen was auf dem spiel steht wenn
man nur sagt es ist irgendeine
abgefahrene willkürliche politik den
russen den geld nicht mehr zu schicken
natürlich werden die deutschen dann
damit kommen aber wenn wir uns sagt was
wird ein beitrag die machen für die
ukraine was sein beitrag sie zur
europäischen frieden machen dass keiner
denkt daran einfach so länder angreifen
wenn sie die deutschen das sagen
dann werden die auch ein bisschen opfern
und ich bin auch überzeugt dass diese
verzehnfachung der gaspreise in eine
sehr liquide gasmarkt auch nicht das
ende der geschichte ist sondern
alternativen werden kommen ja wo sollen
die denn herkommen ich sage immer die
die am lng tanker aus usa die neuen
rosinenbomber wenn sie
also das sind ja ich meine wir haben
hält sogar relativ volle gasspeicher der
größten über die regierung aber da ist
genau dieses teure gas tritt also
aktuell läuft es doch so die regierung
hat ja ein riesen kredit gegeben dafür
dass man jetzt am weltmarkt zu jedem
beliebigen preis gas kauft dadurch
treiben wir selber den preis mit hoch
muss man auch wissen wir ruinieren auch
andere länder mit die nämlich also
gerade ärmere länder die können kein gas
mehr kaufen weil wir die preise
hochtreiben aber nicht nur das sondern
dieses teure gas was jetzt in den
speichern es wird ja irgendwann
verbraucht von den familien von den
unternehmen und dort und die müssen dann
diese ehrenpreise bezahlen wir zehnmal
so viel wie in der vergangenheit das ist
welche kapazitäten gerade in mehrere
kleine steht niemand vor 20 jahren hat
keiner gedacht amerika kommt von
steinkohle weg heute sind die co2
emission von amerika auf den punkt von
1990 obwohl der wirtschaft drei prozent
pro jahr wächst wegen diese schiefergas
und neue technologien unendlich ja nein
schiefergas ist nicht so schädlich wie
eine offene tages mine hier in jülich
und sowas wenn man wasser denkt
schiefergas
es ist schwierig aber die welt bei dem
ab az und weil man muss auch denken der
einheiten vor zwei jahren war so gering
dass leute bezahlt haben das sollte ihr
öl lagern und jetzt ist der preis sehr
hoch aber diese preis ist ja lass tisch
das heißt die anbieter werden dann die
zapfen wieder andrehen und die pipelines
im gang ist zb ein energie prozent